yes and what do you think I love it at
same time it's like seeing little
mark-paul tell them what you do to me
whenever you see me that's what she does
should I say no like this my pop timeout
I'll get back in and he's like I can
only do that second girl do that and I'm
like no I can't do very possessive of my
time you never it never ends you know
that's why everybody wants to see it
again all right let's talk back about
passage and what is this disease I'm
gonna let you guys kind of explain what
this disease so okay I'll introduce
myself I'm Haley acoustic I play dr.
Jonas Lea in the passage and this
disease is well that's the thing we
don't know what it is and that's what
we're doing experiments on it we're
trying to find cures for certain
diseases especially cancer and we
stumbled upon a virus that gets passed
and then we try to contain it contain
the virus and then try to learn from it
and use it on people to see if we can
find the healing factors of it but as
you find out the military has a heavy
presence and the military also wants to
mine the virus to make super soldiers
it's got a lot of elements there's a lot
of what you could disc this can be
useful it could be a good bad and then
they give it to a ten-year-old right yes
and I'm sooo nice at me I play Emma
Belafonte I could see much about my
character just yet but she has a crazy
background and a span and explained more
in the first season but changed up
finding
well gassed and just having a $5
relationship with him and they're on the
run
all right there clearly there are lots
of special effects and lots of crazy
the makeup is crazy and all that kind of
stuff how he wakes up in the morning
yeah a lot what are some of the stunts
and special effects and how much of the
show will be that I don't think we know
you know I mean we I think given what
we've seen in the pilot is a great
balance between having a sci-fi show and
then a this relationship that we have
which is really at the center of the
show as well
so there's I think there's a good
balance for everyone who's watching the
show to say oh I love the sci-fi
elements of it but as well as the
release or different heartfelt stories
the heartfelt stuff all right how much
funny having on the set hanging out with
these guys I learned so much from them
especially me I think that's what she
was about to say is it's an awesome
experience to be able to work with
people I've never met so many people
find I'm like oh my gosh
so doesn't mean you know when I'm acting
with them it's a great experience and I
learned and did you be able to be in the
same room with them and just like
interact and just act with them as
just listening you I figured it out now
it's the reboot of Saved by the Bell
that your daughter yes I had a thing
with Lisa turtle I like that story will
put netflix 2019 all right when can we
see past because not till January right
January 2019 the passage I know we're
shooting it now we're gonna be in an
Atlanta filming and we're gonna film the
entire season this year and then it'll
come out in January of 2019 on Fox
hopefully around the same time as a
Super Bowl or at least we'll get some
promotion of the Super Bowl so yeah
we're in a good position and it'll go
it'll go at nine years do you know yet I
don't know the night no you don't know
the night okay we can't wait what is the
one thing you want fans out there to
know about the show the one thing one
fans to know about a minute it's you
know I think it's gonna be a you know
we've already got an audience because of
the book yes you know so if you enjoyed
the book you know I think you're gonna
enjoy this it's you know it's it's got
so many things that it's got post the
public post apocalyptic easy for you and
it's got in the virals it's got
heartfelt stories between these two is
also a tragic story we have best friends
and how we get to our situation this
there's so many different little stories
going in in the whole show there's a lot
of elements and it jumps back in time it
goes on
it's right before you guys go I know
this is marks first time to comic-con
what about you guys I've never seen
first time you're a third time time I
think have you given them any advice
about what's gonna happen going across
into there
I know it's pretty crazy but I'm excited
though are you I am did you bring a
costume here's my costume
there you go eight years is inside of me
she's like show-off girl sure possible
you guys thank you so much thank you
congratulations thank you
[Music]